again just as yesterday we've got two
hours uh this afternoon now from two to
three then a half hour break and then
from
3 30 to
4 30. um
dan back to you thanks
uh welcome back
thank you frederick
uh so okay so the second part of today's
um
tutorial or introduction
uh is going to focus on
unmeasured confounding so settings where
you haven't measured all the relative
variables
and sort of uh both kind of from
extending what we've talked about
already a little bit like the constraint
based search to a setting where
you haven't measured all the relevant
variables and then and then the sort of
second half of the second half i'll talk
about some more recent
alternative approaches to calls of
discovery that aren't necessarily neatly
in the constraint based or the score
based uh paradigm
so uh so so far
what we've talked about
today
in the phrasing the problem as learning
a dag or equivalence class of dags has
kind of taken on this
this fantasy of having observed all the
relevant variables in in the problem
that we're studying but of course in
reality in almost any application you
can think of perhaps there are some
exceptions but applications in genetics
and in neuroscience and in the social
sciences
there
are the real causal processes uh
probably include a bunch of variables
that are not represented in our data
unmeasured variables i'll call them
latent or
hidden variables and i'm just using
these as synonyms
pose a real problem for reliable causal
inference drawing reliable causal
conclusions
in
a lot of domains
so
the one way of thinking about this is to
broaden the starting point to assume
that rather than assume
uh a that there's some true causal dag
over the x's that rather there's some
larger dag over a larger variable set
which i'll just call x union l so x will
be the observed stuff
and l stands for latent and so this can
be a a a size a vector of any size you
can think of that they're not
restricting the cardinality of the
latent variables in any way but we only
observe x so we observe some you know
reduction or marginalization of this
larger
larger
causal process
um
and thinking about this kind of
just to
try and
um
introduce some intuition just thinking
about two variables at a time
saying you have x and y
and you know that they're associated
known to be dependent
so what are the possible causal
processes that can explain this
dependence or give rise to this
dependence
well obviously
uh it might be that there's a direct
causal relation between the two of them
which goes in one of two directions from
y to x or x to y it might be that
neither causes the other but rather
there are some unmeasured common cause
of them both l a latent factor it might
be that that common cause coexists with
a direct causal relationship so they
might exist together
there might be some sort of feedback
relationship if you think of x and
y as you know maybe measurements of some
equilibrium process so interventions on
x will change the distribution of y
interventions on y will change the
distribution of x
uh or there might be a selection bias so
it might be that they only appear
associated because
x and y
both
influence the process by which the
sample was taken so if you think about
selectively sampling from some some
population of interest if you
selectively sample on the basis of x and
y in the conditional distribution x and
y will look associated even if they're
not causally related to each other you
can actually see this based on
uh
stuff that we learned previously this is
a kind of collider right so conditional
on being s equals one so say s equals
one means you're in the sample zero
means they're not in the sample x and y
will look associated and combinations of
the last two can coexist with all these
other possibilities
i'm going to ignore the last two
possibilities for the purposes of this
talk so i'm going to assume no selection
bias and no
feedback no cycles and just say that
there's this finite set of possibilities
that can uh give rise to any observed
association either direct calls a
relationship in one of two directions a
common cause or a combination of those
so how could we pos so if those are
that's kind of nice because it's it's
just a finite number of options really
right there's only
five structures up here and you might
want to distinguish between them or
among them
uh how could you possibly distinguish
between these possibilities from
observed conditional dependence facts
well in general with just those two
variables you can't at least not without
making
additional stronger assumptions so we
can distinguish between those different
possibilities with just x and y because
they all apply the same restriction on
the observable distribution p of x and y
that's the thing that we have available
to us to make inferences from
in particular no restrictions at all
they just all imply that there's some
association between x and y so it
doesn't factor x
however with more than two variables
patterns of independence may emerge
which can narrow down the structure at
least when you in addition to when you
make additional assumptions like
faithfulness
for example
so say now i have three measured
variables and one unmeasured latent
so if this was the true structure uh
that generated my data over these uh
these three variables
we can see from d separation that y and
z are not independent given x or at
least they're not d separated given x so
given faithfulness they're also not
independent given x why is that because
there's a d connecting path that goes
through l right so z to x to l to y is a
d connecting path and so they'll be
uh
conditionally dependent
whereas
if there wasn't such an l
if there was no l that was a common
cause of x and y
now d separation tells us that actually
x sorry z and y are independent given x
because they're de-separate
so that means that there's
a difference in the implied conditional
independence constraints between these
two models over just the observables so
z x and y are observables l is not and
there's a difference between what these
two models if these were the only two
models we were going to consider we can
test this conditional independence and
decide between the two models
to get to make things a little more
complicated you can imagine larger
patterns that emerge with more than just
a few variables so this particular
graph
i should say these this graph and the
previous one can might look kind of
familiar to you from a kind of
instrumental variables perspective and
the kind of interesting thing about this
structure
is that
here's an example where it sort of seems
like i have two things that act as
instrumental variables if you're
familiar with that in the sense that
there's no effect of disease on the
outcome uh except through the exposure
or treatment x
um
and
this particular dag implies over the set
of observables this list of conditional
independence constraints okay assuming
following from d separation and
faithfulness assumption
whereas this structure in which there is
no such l implies a different set of
conditional dependence constraints so we
can just flip for example if you look at
the bottom two it's about whether y and
z's are independent given x's
[Music]
if you condition r never mind sorry so
it's a collider so they're going to be
yeah i was i was looking at the block
anyways
so the reason i like
to put this example up is because
um in the kind of algorithms that i'll
talk about in a second like the fci
algorithm these kind of like y-shaped
y-shaped structures
where you have sort of independent
sources
of variation
can be very informative about the
presence or absence of unmeasured
confounding between something you care
about like x and y
and we'll see that uh in the algorithm i
present that like
the
arrows in which it's identified whether
that arrow hides an unmeasured
confounder or not are exactly ones of
this kind of form the ones that
in which the
covariates
give you a set of conditional
independence constraints that
distinguishes the
latent model from the not latent model
uh here's another example
in some cases a pattern of conditional
independence may suggest to you
unmeasured confounding
because there is no
non-confounded model no dag model over
those variables that satisfies the
observed set of conditional dependence
constraints in particular if
if this were the structure if i had an
unmeasured variable here l
then again just using d separation
and faithfulness you get a set of
conditional independence constraints
and uh and you should be able to see
that there's no there's no dag that will
satisfy exactly these independence
constraints over these four variables
why is that so if i imagine a dag over
these four variables
in order to
in order to satisfy these dependencies
it has to be uh there has to be some
edge between x2 and x3 right because
they're dependent
and i have to orient it in one direction
or the other
but if i orient that edge from say x2 to
x3
then that should imply that x2 and x4
are marginally independent but dependent
when i condition on x3 right because
it'll be a collider
and but x1 to x2 to x3 in that case
would be 1 and 3 would be independent
given x2
maybe it helps to draw this
so i can imagine
so if this were the if this were the dag
then i would have x1 independent of x3
given x2 but that violates this
constraint that is implied by the model
or if i oriented the edge in the
opposite direction
then uh
x2 should be independent of x4 given x3
but that violates this constraint in the
model
right so
it's a kind of quick proof that there's
no there's no dag model that represents
exactly this set of conditional
dependence constraints so you have to
sort of posit something else like an
unmeasured confounder to explain this
pattern of conditional dependence
constraints
so
um
so the way that we do this is by leaving
behind the class of dags and cp dags and
start thinking about a broader class of
graphical models
mixed graphs so mixed just generically
referring to having multiple kinds of
edges and in particular mix graphs here
will refer to graphs that have both
directed and these bi-directed edges
where the bi-directed edges similar to
what you saw in the
in the presentation yesterday
uh represent unmeasured confounding so
this model
uh is represented by this graph
and that captures
just the conditional independence
relations on this list
so the nice thing uh so
so
fortunately there exists procedures
that allow for arbitrary latent
variables arbitrary in the sense that
we're not making any assumptions about
how many there are
or which other variables they might
affect
or distributional assumptions about them
really
and they search in this kind of larger
space of mixed graphs
uh specifically i'll spend a lot of time
over the next hour talking about
constrain a constraint based procedure
which follows a very similar logic to
the pc algorithm called fci which stands
for fast causal inference
um so we're not we're going to sort of
abandon the hope of finding a dag or a
cp dag representation and search over
this
larger space of graphs
so there's there are um
these mixed graphs this example i have
over here is specifically an acyclic
directed mix graph which is often
abbreviated admg
and you there's a
procedure for taking a latent variable
dag
and constructing the implied admg graph
which is a unique construction from
latent variable dag to this mixed graph
in a way that preserves all the
conditional independence information
among the observed variables
and that procedure is called this latent
projection
so if i begin with a dag g
and think about the induced dependent
structure when some variables have been
marginalized out which is kind of the
mathematical
operation operationalization of having
not observed the variable
um i want to preserve the conditional
independence relations in the marginal
distribution meaning over the x's
and represent those with an admg
so this latent projection operation
starts with a dag over vertices x and l
and
spits out a new graph with vertices
v prime and e prime
uh in the following way so the vertices
v prime are just going to be over x
and there's going to be an x between any
sorry an edge between any two
x's uh if there exists a directed path
from
x i to x j in the original dag
with all intermediate nodes on the path
belonging to l
and the sort of special the
a directed path that doesn't go through
any l is a special case of this because
uh there are no nodes on the path right
so if i have a directed edge between x i
and xj then all nodes on the path go
through l vacuously there are no nodes
on the path and so i'll always put a
directed edge in the latent projection
and then there'll be a bi-directed edge
this double-headed
arrow
if there exists a path from x i to x j
of the form
um you know with an arrow headed x i and
an arrowhead xj where every intermediate
node on the path is in l and no
consecutive edges on the path or of the
form
of colliders you know so i'm not i'm
sort of excluding the possibility that
there are these colliders on the pathway
between x i and x j
so this is a sort of way of saying that
there is a d connect a d connecting path
between
x i
and x j
through stuff in l
and that induces a dependence between x
i and x j in the marginal
and the nice thing although it may not
be the most
uh well
let me just go through a couple of
examples this first one we saw up here
the latent projection of this
is the graph that we had seen two slides
ago right it has a bi-directed edge
between x2 and x3 why is that well all
these directed edges
get carried over automatically because
they satisfy that first condition
that uh
that there's an edge between them a
directed path between them with all
intermediate names on the path
and there's a bi-directed edge between
them because they satisfy the second
condition namely that there's a
a path
from where l is this variable in the
middle that goes to x i and goes to x j
so that
sends us from this latent variable dag
to the admg latent projection
and
importantly this other graph which is a
different dag over a different set of
variables implies the same latent
projection right if i follow the logic
i'll still just get an edge from x1 to
x2 from x4 to x3 and a bi-directed edge
between x2 and x3
so really an infinite number of possible
latent variable dags get can get
projected down to the same admg as long
as they represent the same d separation
relationships between the x's
okay
and uh
the kind of nice thing about this
construction is that admgs preserve
conditional independence relationships
among the observed variables
using a criterion that's basically just
d separation but for mixed graphs so d
separation is the d stands for directed
um when you talk about mixed graphs you
talk about m separation for mixed
and i won't formally define it here but
it's literally just the same definition
of de-separation you saw yesterday but
just allow for the fact that arrows have
two possible endpoints they could be
bi-directed or directed and you get m
separation and the result is that for
for any
set of
any three sets of variables
um
they're d separated and the dag if and
only if they're m separated in the mda
admg
that's created by latent projection
so kind of like latent projection is
created to preserve this kind of
conditional independence relationship
any questions on this before we go on
yeah
so why um
why is the case that so we're we're
allowing i think uh in the in the
definition for a variable l
to affect many
um
uh observed uh
very very variables like it could affect
three
so why is it like not useful i i asked
kind of this
uh yesterday
hey
why is it not so useful to consider
hyper edges to describe uh when l
i mean it blows things up
combinatorially but but why can you
really
throw away that and just think uh fair
pairwise what's the
like probability in intuition behind
that
yeah that's a good question so you might
so i sort of to summarize the idea that
you might think that you can
distinguish in your latent projection
between latent variables that are causes
of just two observed variables versus
three or more observed variables and you
could come up with a representation like
that
i think the point is that
uh
here they're not needed because
because d separation only really cares
about
uh the end points of pathways
right so like the the point is that it's
all constructed to make this true
so
d separation between sets is like just d
separation between all the elements of
each set on either side and so the the
criteria for d separation is like is
there a path from x1 to xj that
satisfies some properties right
so if all you care about is preserving d
separation relationships you just need
to know is there a path that goes
through l's in the right way or not
and so i i would i would agree that you
could do this construction as sort of
more informative in a sense but it's not
going to be more informative about d
separation
if i could just say something about that
so
just uh okay
these these properties of deseparation
are deep connectivity whether what's
faithful or not um sort of
it's the same but it's not true that the
set of probability distributions
supported that are
consistent with the graph are the same
so
if i have a chain and i have a single
hidden variable that kind of
you can talk to all the visible
variables that's not the same thing as
having many hidden variables that you
speak to
just two at a time the classes probably
distribution supported are not the same
but the d separations are the same yeah
they're the same independence model but
i think
the illusion is that
there's other potential implications of
a latent variable model that affects a
bunch of things at the same time for
example
in a later workshop you might talk about
like inequality constraints between
uh between the measured variables and
those are all just sort of ignored by
this
criterion for that
so it's the same independence model
among the marginal this is the kind of
way that i did it
okay so
so admgs are cool they have this
property which is nice
um so
they also have a relatively clear causal
interpretation because you can easily
think about the causal dag that
generated them right like you can see
that if i'm if i give you an admg
that you know direct the edges represent
that there's a causal pathway from one
of the variables to the other and
bi-directed edges represent that there's
some unmeasured common cause of them
both
um so that's nice
um and there's a lot of associated
theory for admgs so yesterday you
learned about the id algorithm and
they're sort of general identification
results for if i give you an admg how to
calculate
post-interventional distributions of
various sorts or even more complicated
kinds of interventions soft
interventions stochastic interventions
whatever there's a lot of theory
for
identification of causal quantities
given in admg but they're not ideal
targets for structural learning or
causal discovery
at least not yet and the reason is that
mark so there's a few reasons the first
one is that markov equivalence for
admg's is complicated so with dags
there was a really simple
characterization of markov equivalent
dags right same adjacencies and same
unshielded colliders or immoralities so
that's how you can check whether two
dags are a markup equivalent and then
there was a representation a graphical
representation of the entire equivalence
class which is also quite neat it was
just like a graph with directed edges
and undirected edges and we could
characterize the properties of that that
representation for admgs there is no
such nice thing so uh markov equivalent
graphs might even have a different
number of adjacencies than each other
and so there's not going to be one
convenient
graphical representation that you can
use to summarize the markov equivalence
class which means you can't search for
the markov equivalence class in a
straightforward way
secondly and this is maybe not so
important for present purposes but
parametrization of admg's is kind of
complicated so if i give you an admg and
i say i want to associate with this like
a linear structural equation model
um
it's it's not
as simple as in the case of a dag to to
say that the linear structural equation
model has parameters theta 1 theta 2
whatever and that implies all the same
in uh all the same
distributional properties that the admg
represents um it's simple in some cases
but complicated in others
and then perhaps most importantly for
the purposes of what i'm talking about
here which is a kind of constraint based
search procedure is that admgs are not
maximal
maximality is this property
of a graph that a graph may or may not
exhibit
which says that
for every pair of vertices
a non-adjacency implies that there are
some
separating set meaning there's some set
that makes them conditionally
independent in the associated model
so this was true
for all dags because d separation just
gives you this so if there's no if
they're not adjacent that means they're
d separated given some set and that
means they're conditionally independent
given that set
but admgs don't have this property
automatically so there may be
missing edges that don't correspond to
any particular conditional independence
or separation of this sort
so
as a kind of classic example here's a
admg on four variables
which represents this kind of latent
variable model between x2 and x4
that's not maximum
can anybody identify why
can you go back to the depth to the
definition
so it's not maximal if there's a
non-adjacency
that doesn't have a corresponding
conditional independence
over the x's
there's only one as a hint there's one
non-adjacency in this graph between x1
and x4
otherwise everything else is adjacent i
think that's all i have to do yeah so if
you condition at x2 there's a path from
x1 to x2 to x4 if you condition on x3
there's a path from x1 to x3 to x4 so
right so conditioning you have to think
about what are the possible d separating
sets
uh in this graph between x1 and x4
there's the empty set there's x2 x3 and
x2 and x3 together
and the question is is
are the paths between them
deconnecting or not given those
conditioning sets so as the simplest one
uh x1 and x4 are are they deep connected
given the empty set yes they're just
like this
connecting path between them so that's
they're they're not d separated from the
empty set and then yes are they
deseparated given x2
and no there's a deconnecting path even
when i condition on x2 because x2 is
going to be a collider so i will go to
this path for example and i'll
make them deconnected x3 similarly if i
condition on x3 are they d separated
given x3 no there's a deconnect impact
such that
all colliders on that path i forget
which definition you guys learned
yesterday i think in terms of deep
connection so here's a de-connecting
path
this way and and i'm conditioning them
both and it's the same thing again so no
matter what i condition on there's a
deconnecting path between x1 and x4 so
it means there's no deseparation between
them given any subset of the variables
and so that missing edge does not
correspond to any d separation
so that's uh
that's
inconvenient from the perspective of
causal discovery or structure learning
because when we talked about the pc
algorithm
sort of a key step was that
whenever we observed a conditional
independence
we could remove the edge knowing that
there was some sort of de-separation
between them
but you can't do that with general admgs
so this one this is what motivated
uh thinking about a kind of specific
subclass of admgs
called maximal ancestral graphs so in
order to make a kind of pc style search
possible where i can test conditional
independence constraints and remove
edges from some sort of super graph
we'll focus on this class of mags
and for the purposes of our present
discussion think about mags as just a
special case of admgs in general there's
a footnote here which says that actually
the sort of full definition of mags is a
bit more complicated and allows for
directed bi-directed and undirected
edges to co-exist and that's because uh
mags are sort of
in part invented not only to deal with
um
uh systems with unmeasured confounding
but also with that selection bias
problem that i alluded to earlier uh but
i'm going to just ignore that for the
purposes of this talk it just makes
things
more difficult to write down
but if you go back to like the original
mags paper you'll see all the theory
proved with
directed by directed and undirected
edges
so for our for our purposes we'll define
a mag as follows firstly we need a kind
of
a name for variables that are connected
by a bi-directed edge so we have parents
children ancestors all these things so
we're going to call edges connected by a
bi-directed one
spouses sp
uh don't blame me for this i did not
come up with it um
and
we're going to define an ancestral graph
to be one in which no variable is an
ancestor of either its parents or its
spouses
so the first part of that if you ignore
the spouse's bit it says that no
variable is an ancestor of its parents
that just means no cycles right so
that's true of dags as well if you were
an ancestor of your parents there'd be a
cycle from from you to you
but sort of the additional bit here is
that there also can't be a path
from a variable to any of its spouses so
those are paths that kind of look like
um
look like this
like you can't have a path that
leads you to be
an ancestor of of any of your spouses so
that's called the ancestrality property
of a graph
an ancestral graph
is one that satisfies this property
so it does not contain any directed or
sort of almost directed
cycles
okay
so that's uh that's a subclass of admgs
and then a second step is that we're
also going to restrict
two ancestral graphs that are maximal so
ancestral graphs that satisfy this
maximality property we discussed a few
minutes ago that any missing edge
corresponds to a
a conditional independence
and we there's a construction for how
you go from a latent variable dag to a
mag that we'll get to in just a second
but before that let me let me say that
mags
have pros and cons as a kind of object
of inference
the major pro is that they're maximal by
construction
so if we ever find a conditional
independence we know that that
corresponds to some sort of missing edge
and we could do a kind of pc style
search
uh the second benefit is that you can
characterize markov equivalent mags
maximum ancestral graphs there's a few
papers that have gone through the hard
work of defining both how to check if
two mags are markov equivalent and
represent the entire equivalence class
of mags for a specific graph with a
single graphical object which we'll get
to in a second it's called a pag partial
ancestral graph
and then on top of that they inherit
other nice properties of admgs namely
that m separation works out in all the
same way so if something is if two
variables are m separated given a third
in the mag then they're d separated
given that variable and the underlying
dag that was used to construct the mag
so those are all nice properties that
mags have
the cons however is that they're going
to have a much more
confusing interpretation or indirect
interpretation causally speaking as
compared to admgs not that you can't
like if you
spend time with mags the interpretation
of them becomes i think somewhat
intuitive eventually but it's like not
easy to just read it off in the same way
that it's easy with dags and admgs
i'll get to what i mean by that in a
second
and also that they're less informative
than admgs in a sense that
mags will sort of not necessarily always
distinguish to you whether there is only
a causal relationship an ancestral
relationship or both an ancestral
relationship and a common cause between
two variables they sort of hide
information in a sense so let me say
what i mean by that
so the interpretation of a mag
is that if
if you have a directed edge from x i to
xj in a mag
then xi is an ancestor of xj and the
underlying dag that was used to
construct it
so ancestry meaning that there's a
directed causal path in the underlying
dag regardless of what i marginalized
out and so uh like if i think
that that's what it means for it to be a
cause or have a causal influence on xj
then that sort of property is being
preserved here
the bi-directed edge means that x-i is
not an ancestor of xj and xj is not an
ancestor of xi
so which implies in this space of latin
variable dags that there's a latent
common cause of them both since those
are the only ways in which you could
have that non-s
non-ancestrality relationship and still
have a dependence
so the kind of idea is that
arrowheads in a mag tell you about
ancestrality and non-ancestrality
and that's a less intuitive concept than
like direct causation in a dag there's
no notion of direct
uh
causation that quite fits with the mag
because you've marginalized out a bunch
of stuff so it might be that the path
was very indirect but it ended up with
an ancestral relationship between x i
and xj
and and the key is that an ancestral
relationship and latent confounding can
coexist
so just because
all i said was that x is an ancestor of
x j but i didn't say there's also no
common cause between x i and xj
so in in particular a directed edge like
this in a mag
is sort of ambiguous between
the underlying model has no confounding
versus the underlying model does have
some confounding right there is such an
l and an ancestral relationship
coexisting
and we'll get a little bit later uh
we'll get to a criterion where you can
sometimes distinguish between these two
possibilities from a mag but it's not as
direct as just reading reading the graph
yes
so
there's some true model
x union l
so obviously you can always model with
name
atm g but
can i always model it with one of these
i haven't started this like fully
expressive or what uh
yeah good question so for any
so
for any starting dag over x and l i can
construct a mags that satisfy these
properties from that underlying theme
and what that thing will represent is
the ancestrality relationships now
underlying dag and it'll preserve
conditional independence relationships
using m separation among the margins it
will not tell you everything that might
you might want to know about that
underlying debt
as a quick example it won't tell you how
many latent variables there are right
like it doesn't it's not fully
informative about all aspects of the
underlying structure well that's
something we couldn't even ask for
because
but it won't tell you the minimum or it
won't or
no it will tell you and what's up it
will tell you basically only what i just
said ancestrality relationships and
separations yeah i think here
well i was gonna say this is the
construction so but i can answer this
question also a clarification question
from zoom is there not a special case
with an apfg that rules out the counter
examples with extra assumptions on the
structure of the
drafting edge
that you didn't have
yes yeah so i'll get to that on this
next slide with an example of how that
works
um
so if you have
if if this is supposed to represent a
situation
in which there really was
was an l
that was like a
common cause of these two things
um the man will sort of
hide this by adding extra edges so it's
not like you can't represent this thing
but um it won't look like this
well i was thinking there was the tar
yesterday's tar example is a very small
example that could be disallowed
so what mac would you give for that
target
yeah so uh
in that case it's
um
it's gonna put a directed edge here
instead of a bi-directed edge but that
directed edge is sort of hiding that
this linen variable
so if i if i start with that graph
and i write down
the mag projection of it
over x y and z
so this tells me true things about
ancestral relationships it is true that
x is an ancestor of y and so that's
represented
in the underlying graph that's
represented by this edge here and z is
an ancestor that's the answer to z these
are ancestry y as well
so and all the m separations over
the x y z are also preserved namely
there's none of them
and that's it so so this edge
is sort of like hiding the unmeasured
confounder there um but there's a
criterion that we'll get to a little bit
which you can learn sometimes whether
it's hiding the measuring component or
not
and
we would have the same cost even though
we didn't have that latency
i mean if this was the truth
at all um
hold on
could i just make a quick comment here
if if the dag was x to z to y then the
mag would not have an edge from x to y
just
why does x
if there was no compounding between x
and y
oh sorry you're right yeah you're right
so
if but and there's n there's no direct
edge right so
so if this was true
then the mag is actually just this and
that's because of this part of the
definition so adjacencies in the mag
come from these things called inducing
paths and the underlying
uh
underlying dag so an inducing path is
like a somewhat
uh thank you thomas for the correction
so reducing path is like a somewhat
confusing definition to look at but the
intuition is that
these paths
inducing path through l
induces a conditional dependence
between the endpoints of that path after
i've marginalized out l
it's like the simplest inducing path is
just like the direct common cause
thing
so if i have x i and
xj
so intuitively l induces a dependence
between x i and j
and there's a path uh
so that definition is kind of vacuously
satisfied because there's no colliders
on the path
and so it's a path uh
in which every vertex except except l is
a collider
cell's not a collider it induces
dependence between xi and xj but it's a
bit confusing to go from this definition
exactly to that property
you'll have to trust me on it i guess
for now but you can prove that if
there's an inducing path relative to l
between x i and x j then there'll be a d
connection
uh between them in the underlying graph
so so so the construction then the
latent projection going from latent
variable dag
to a mag over
uh just the x's
is one that
decides adjacencies first based on
inducing pads
and then orients those adjacencies based
on ancestrality
so if
xi is an ancestor of xj then orient it
uh
yeah oriented as x i to xj
if the reverse is true oriented in the
first direction and if neither is an
ancestor of the other put a
double-headed arrow between them
so it's like a somewhat more confusing
version of the latent projection
operation for admgs that requires this
auxiliary concept of inducing paths
um and how does that how does that play
out in terms of the
example the counter example for
maximality we we saw earlier so earlier
the admg we saw was like a latent
projection of this graph right
it had a bi-directed edge between x2 and
x3 and if you carry out the mag latent
projection for that graph you end up
uh
sort of filling in
that non-adjacency that we saw earlier
that didn't have any corresponding
conditional independence with an edge so
they're adjacent so namely because
there's an inducing path
between
x1 and x4 relative to l
so it's a path in which
uh
going back some definition
uh on which every vertex not in l
uh is a collider so there's a path in
which this is a collider and this is a
collider
and induces the uh the dependence
between x1 and x4
so this graph on the bottom this latent
projection
mag latent projection of the original
dag
again is kind of
informative
for in the sense that it's not lying to
you about ancestral relationships
but it's less informative than the the
general admg because it's sort of
ambiguous about what this edge between
x1 to x4 means is it hiding and measured
confounding or not
makes sense
so
um
given all this
uh
we can represent an equivalence class of
maximal ancestral graphs with a single
graphical object so this is like the
equivalence or the analogy to a cp dag
in the case of dags
in the case of mags we have pads
and if you spend enough time
in causality research acronyms just
become
like they flow over you and they don't
matter anymore so so so cp daggers the
daggers as pegs are the mags
and um
and pads
are special in that they have
multiple edge types to represent
ambiguity about markov equivalents in
particular they have these additional
circle marks
uh where the circles hide or
underdetermine whether there's in fact a
tail
there or an arrowhead
so
ultimately you can have
what is it six kinds of edges in a peg
you can have a directed edge a
bi-directed edge
a circle arrow edge a circle circle edge
uh actually that's it for without
without selection bias but if you allow
undirected edges you can have those as
well as two
so so this
uh representation of an equivalence
class tells me that there's some bag in
the equivalence class in which this is a
bi-directed arrow for example and some
mag in the equivalence class where it's
a directed area from five to four and
from four to five and so forth
uh but also a tricky thing
um
the tricky thing about
reading tags is that not necessarily all
combinations of filling in the circles
can
exist at once in the markov equivalence
class
right so
if i
include if i filled both of these
circles in with an arrowhead that would
form an unshielded collider at x4
so that's not really part of the
equivalence class because otherwise i
would have
oriented it as such
and so it's really just saying that
there's some graph
in the equivalence class in which that's
an arrowhead and some graph in the
equivalence class in which that's a tail
and same for that
circle as well but not necessarily that
they're all uh
every combination is equally possible
okay
so
uh as a kind of example
this is a really nice paper by jiji
zhang
in jmlr from 2008 that goes through a
lot of uh properties of mags and pegs
but yeah
uh i just have a question about the
circle circle edge actually
so is it true that
uh
so as far as i understand if you have a
circle
that means essentially that in the
acronyms class there is at least one
graph mag where there is a arrowhead at
least one where there is a tail but if
you have a circle circle edge does that
imply there will be a bi-directed one in
the equivalence class
yeah it's just about circles right yeah
good point so it's just about filling in
circles not necessarily
entire
edges
thank you
so as an example
um this is from this paper as a small
graph
uh so there's a small written variable
model you have a bunch of observed
things and you have an unmeasured
latency called profession here which
influences income and smoking behavior
and so you can ask like what are the
different bags
that are latent projections of this
uh latent variable dag and here are two
markov equivalent
mags
which differ in their arrow heads right
so in this case i have an arrowhead of
eye in this case
in this case i have an arrowhead or i in
this case i don't and an arrowhead at
parent smoking habits versus not and i
could represent that whole thing
with a tag
that places circles
at those key locations
okay
okay um
so
given all that background machinery
we can now
define a
pc style constraint based
model selection procedure that searches
in the space of tags
and it off it can operate in pc like pc
in the sense that it just needs to look
at every
pair of variables and test conditional
dependence constraints given separate
possible separating sets
and when it finds them it can remove an
edge
and then it has to do some some logic
similar to pc to orient edges with
arrowheads when it finds unshielded
colliders and then propagates some
additional rules that basically
uh follow from the abstract properties
of of the class of mags or packs
kind of key difference is so if you if
you look at this and kind of compare to
a piece not that i think you've
memorized pc but
but it should sort of look familiar to
you that you're looking at like subsets
of adjacencies
testing some conditional independence
thing and if you find it you remove
moving edge except here now you're
starting off with a complete graph where
you have circle circle
edges everywhere
you remove
remove circle circle edges whenever you
find a conditional independence
and then you orient things using the
collider rule again so basically i put
arrowheads to replace the circles
uh when i find that they're pairwise
uh you know i and k are adjacent and k
and j are adjacent but i and j are not
adjacent
and that k is not in the separating set
so that's all so like this whole first
stage is exactly the same as pc except
the circle circle edges everywhere
and i'm using by the way this asterisk
here to denote like it could be any
symbol it could be a circle or a tail or
a arrowhead
and then there's an additional step
where now you kind of have to do the
whole thing again
but looking only at subsets when you're
searching for separating sets you have
to look at subsets of this specially
constructed set called pds uh
possible dsip
so the definition of which is down here
at the bottom sorry it's a bit small
but possible dsep is a set uh
constructed based on the location of
adjacencies and colliders in the graph
which
um
has this property
that
if there exists a separating set between
x i and x j
that's a subset of x
it must be a subset of possible d set
so you can show that for mags and tags
that these
these separating sets
are all contained in this like
relatively large set called possible
dsep which is like
you can construct from partial
orientation information about the graph
it's sort of the analog too in pc we
said that
if there's a separating set it must be a
subset of one of the parent sets of the
two endpoints
right so this is the like more
complicated version of that if there's a
separating set it must be a subset of
this possible dsep set
and and so that means that um
effectively
like this whole first stage of the
algorithm is really just instrumentally
useful to determine what possible dsep
is for every set of variables and then
you sort of do it again using possible
dsap as your set of potential separating
sets
so i'll go through and i'll look at
every pair or variable and i'll look at
subsets of possible dsep of increasing
cardinality and i'll remove an edge if i
find a
a separating set and i'll save which one
did it and then i'll repeat step 9 which
means basically orient all the colliders
as we did previously and then at the end
i'll apply a set of orientation rules
the orientation rules i didn't reproduce
in these slides they're in this paper
um
they are the first few orientation rules
are just the same as the pc ones they
basically prevent cycles and new
unshielded colliders and then there's
some additional orientation rules that
follow from the
basically the ancestrality property of
mags
and preserving the markov equivalents of
max
so i won't go into that here
but that's fci
so
let's see
um
let me end before going on to the next
bit
let me end with like a kind of quick
demonstration
uh to maybe
prove to you this isn't magic i guess
because oftentimes when you present the
fci algorithm it seems kind of crazy
that you could learn anything
about a latent variable model so really
quick just uh using
a popular r package for causal discovery
called pc out i'm gonna simulate a
little bit of data
uh on five variables with one latent
variable so the true graph that i'm
simulating from in this first little bit
is one that we saw on our slides
uh earlier
so it's the one where
x1
x2
s4 right so where l is latent
and so if you simulate
uh
i'm going to do a sample size of 10 000
so that
i can be relatively confident it won't
make statistical mistakes i'm i'm
simulating from a linear gaussian model
here
with just coefficients that i made up so
i'm going to use the
independence test for gaussian data the
fischer z partial correlation test
and then i'm gonna run fci
uh sufficient statistic is just the data
it's the covariance matrix and the
sample size independence test is the
test that i choose to plug in i'm
setting the alpha to .05 because it
doesn't matter for 10 000 variables at
this point
the number of variables is four so the
data only consists of x one x two x
three x four not l because l is latent
and i'm printing out verbose
output just for fun
and
uh and then the graph that i get out at
the end the default
visualization for graphs and
in r is pretty ugly but there's better
ones out there
but the the the graph you get out at the
end is what you expect from the pad
representation of this thing
right namely it puts if you can see it
puts a bi-directed edge between two and
three
it puts arrows into three from four and
into
two from one and then it leaves circles
uh here to represent the markov
equivalents so it's going to estimate
this peg
and so here it did exactly the right
thing
because i gave it enough sample size and
it's only four variables and it's not a
very hard problem but it gives you
exactly the pag representation of this
underlying
dag
okay
and as another example
related to what we saw and actually
just for the sake of comparison what if
i ran pc on this data you might ask so
if i run pc on the same data
i get something that
orients an edge in one direction or the
other incorrectly as we saw before right
it finds the right set of
dependencies in a sense
but it messes up the orientation because
it it has to decide at some stage
whether x2
goes to x3 or vice versa or leave an
undirected edge between them
and in this case based on the order of
the tests it'll just orient it this
direction and so it'll be sort of
correct about some stuff it's correct
about four to three and one to two for
example but it's incorrect about the
relationship between two and three
and you could do exactly the same thing
with ges
although it's a little harder to predict
what it'll do so for ges i can define a
score and so this is the gaussian bic
score i can run ges
and i can plot the results and i
similarly
get a dag that's like kinda wrong right
so it'll in the case of ges
it gets so confused about the
relationship between x2 and x3 that it
just just decides to cover it so that
there's no independence at all
okay
and as another example
um
yes uh so is there uh tests that are for
uh non-parametrical tests
yeah so i mentioned this in the in the
morning presentation that there's a
large literature on non-parametric
independence tests
the two ones that i discussed really
briefly were this kernel-based
conditional dependence test which uses
basically kernel regression to define a
test statistic
and then this
generalized covariance measure test
which uses the expected conditional
covariance as the parameter of interest
and does some sort of non-parametric or
semi-parametric estimate of that thing
and tests with their zero
i was trying to use it but i looked at
the documentation it's in separate
packages typically so and if you look at
the slides from this morning there's a
package called
conned in tests conditional independence
tests and that includes kci and a few
others
and then other packages are kind of
available from
[Music]
the authors or on on screens or whatever
um so but once you once you load in that
package and define the test as i did
above you can just plug it into
these units
okay so let me do another example with
uh that kind of live structure graph
which is kind of key to
orienting things in
fci so in the y structure graph
um
i'm assuming here that the true dag
is z1 and z2
affecting x
which affects y
with possibly this
unmeasured
confounder l between
x and one okay
uh and so
i'll generate again ten thousand data
points for a model that satisfies this
you can see that here i have like that
z1 and z2 effect x and l effect x
x x y and l x y
um
and
i generate data from that model i just
keep the measured stuck so this is just
four variables again z1 z2
x and y
i define the same conditional
independence test and so forth and i
find that if that was the truth
this is the graph that i learned namely
it puts an edge between z and y for both
z1 and z2
because they're not d separated given x
right in the original example we saw
that if this l is really here
then z2
and z1 are both not independent of y
given x because of this
deconnecting path
whereas
if instead
i
do this again setting the
making l no longer a confounder so i
just set the effect of l on x to zero
and
uh
generate the data again
and run fci again
then
it returns
that there's actually no confounder
between x and y right it gives me a
directed edge
uh
between x and y
and
z1 and z2
are not are not ancestors or are not
directly connected to y
in this pag and there's some
circle marks to represent ambiguity
related to markov equivalents
and this is an example of i'll get to
this after
after the break but the directed edge
here actually i can read off from this
graph that it doesn't hide a confounder
in general i wouldn't know right
remember we said that the directed edge
could kind of hide it could mean that
ancestrality
coexists with unmeasured confounding but
there's a criterion i can use which is
satisfied by this graph that tells me
that there's no confounding between x
and y and i can so i'm learning things
are really that there's a ancestral
causal relationship between them but no
confounding relationship between them
and so these kind of y structures end up
being very useful
in fci or related algorithms for
distinguishing between
unmeasured confounding and ancestrality
versus just ancestrality
okay
yeah the circles by z1 and z2 so those
represent that
there could have been a it needed to be
a directed edge there could have been a
latent between yeah there could be a
latent between
x and z2 or x and z1 yes so that could
be oriented as a
double-headed error
okay so i think it's break and we can
pick up after the coffee great
uh 30-minute break we'll be back here at
3 30 for the last round
okay